DOCUMENTS AND JOINS US TO
DESCRIBE WHAT THEY CONTAIN.
CATHERINE?
>> I WAS STILL GOING THROUGH THE
DOCUMENTS RIGHT NOW.
AMONG THE HEADLINES THAT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL SAYS FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER
MICHAEL FLYNN PROVIDED
SUBSTANTIAL COOPERATION WITH
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATORS.
THEY ARE RECOMMENDING THE LOW
END OF SPECTRUM, NO JAIL TIME,
POSSIBLY PROBATION IN THIS CASE.
THE KEY DOCUMENT HERE I HAVE IS
WHAT IS CALLED THE ADDENDUM, IF
YOU CAN COME BACK TO ME BECAUSE
IT HAS VERY IMPORTANT DETAILS.
IT OUTLINES THAT MICHAEL FLYNN
PARTICIPATED IN 19 INTERVIEWS.
PARTS ARE REDACTED BECAUSE OF
ONGOING CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU THE DEPTH AND
THE BREADTH OF THE REDACTIONS.
HERE ON PAGE 2, IT SAYS REDACTED
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION, THE
DEFENDANT HAS PROVIDED
SUBSTANTIAL ASSISTANCE IN A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION AND THEN
YOU CAN SEE THE REST OF THAT IS
REDACTED.
I'M STILL POURING THROUGH THE
RECORDS.
BUT WHAT YOU CAN SEE HERE AS I
SAID IS THE BOTTOM LINE OF THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, THE FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER MIKE
FLYNN HAS PROVIDED SUBSTANTIAL
COOPERATION.
HE'S SAT FOR TWO DOZEN
INTERVIEWED WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL AND PROVIDED
COMMUNICATIONS AND OTHER RECORDS
FOR ONGOING CRIMINAL MATTERS
WHICH HAVE BEEN REDACTED IN THE
PUBLICLY-RELEASED DOCUMENTS THIS
EVENING CITING A NEED TO PROTECT
THE ONGOING INVESTIGATION SO WE
HAVE A RECOMMENDATION ON
SENTENCING FOR MIKE FLYNN, BUT
ALSO VERY STRONG EVIDENCE THAT
THE CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION BY
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL IS ONGOING
AT THIS TIME.
>> Tucker: SO JUST TO BE CLEAR,
THE SENTENCING THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO WOULD BE FOR THE
CRIME TO WHICH HE PLED GUILTY,
WHICH WAS LYING IN THE COURSE OF
THE INVESTIGATION.
SO IT WAS A PERJURY CHARGE.
HE MIGHT HAVE FACED PRISON TIME
FOR THAT.
>> YES, WHICH IS A VIOLATION OF
USC 1001, UP TO FIVE YEARS IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE GIVEN HE
HAS NO PRIOR OFFENSES, THE HIGH
DEGREE OF COOPERATION WAS
EXPECTED THAT IT WOULD BE
BETWEEN ZERO AND SIX MONTHS.THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS RECOMMENDING
NO JAIL TIME HERE BECAUSED ON
HIS COOPERATION.
THE OTHER BIG HEADLINE BASED ON
THE DOCUMENTS IS THAT THIS
ADDENDUM THAT OUTLINES HOW MIKE
FLYNN HAS COOPERATED IS HEAVILY
REDACTED HERE AND THEY'VE DONE
THAT BECAUSE THEY WANT TO KEEP
THAT INFORMATION SECRET, THEY
DON'T WANT IT PUBLIC BECAUSE IT
WOULD TIP THEIR HAND, IF YOU
WILL, TO THE ONGOING CRIMINAL
MATTERS THAT INVOLVED OTHER
INDIVIDUALS.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: AND THERE'S NO
SUGGESTION -- I KNOW YOU JUST
GOT THE DOCUMENTS.
IT'S NOT IMMEDIATELY OBVIOUS
WHAT HE IS COOPERATING ABOUT --
OH SORRY TO TO PUT YOU ON THE
SPOT.
>> YOU'RE NOT AND I WANT TO GIVE
YOU THE BEST ANSWER I CAN
WITHOUT SPECULATING.
IT'S TOO IMPORTANT.
WHAT IT SPEAKS TO IS THAT HE'S
PROVIDING COOPERATION DOCUMENTS
AND TESTIMONY ABOUT ALLEGATIONS
OF COLLUSION WITH THE RUSSIANS
AND MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
I'M STILL GOING THROUGH THE
DOCUMENTS.
I DON'T SEE ANYTHING MORE
SPECIFIC THAN THAT AT THIS TIME
THAT WOULD  DOVE TAIL ELEMENTS
OF THE RECOMMENDATION.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TIP THEIR
HAND TO INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
NOT FACED ANY CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION AT THIS TIME.
>> Tucker: THERE BETTER BE A
HUGE CRIME UNDERLYING THIS.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF
REDACTED.
>> Tucker: WE'RE REALLY GOING
THROUGH A LOT.
SO IF THIS WINDS UP JUST BEING A